Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Marvel infinity saga
re-watch video for Thor we're going to be
breaking down all the Marvel phase 4
Easter eggs avengers endgame connections
that we didn't notice the first time we
watched it so if you're new to the
channel as part of this rewatch we're
actually doing the Infinity Saga box set
giveaway for all the movies all you have
to do to enter that you just leave your
favorite Thor moment from this movie on
the video because we'll be talking about
stuff going all the way up to Marvel
phase 4 careful for spoilers from all
the Marvel movies so far speaking of
which this is the weekend that Black
Widow was supposed to come out in
theaters thank you very much virus for
delaying all movies so which was number
of these Easter eggs as we go along
starting at the beginning of the movie
working our way through shot by shot so
Kenneth Branagh obviously was picked as
director he would later return to do
that intro scene and infinity war the
voice on the calms of the Asgardian
screaming for help when Thanos was
destroying them to take the space stone
the reason why Marvel chose Kenneth
Branagh out to direct the first Thor
movie is because they were doing him
more in the Shakespearean tone of the
classic Thor comics that just the way he
was written so they picked a great
Shakespearean actor and director it
really wasn't until Taika Waititi
creatively rebooted the character in the
franchise for thor ragnarok that they
changed their complete approach to the
Thor mythology the writers actually said
there was a lot of big comic-book stuff
that they had to get rid of when they
were making the movie just for budgetary
reasons originally they were going to
include Thor's brother Bowser from the
comics they were going to do a full-blown
version of the Midgard serpent and a lot
of the big action scenes around the nine
realms especially that last big battle
with the destroyer we're going to be way
bigger but were reduced for budgetary
reasons Kevin Feige would later talk
about how Marvel played it safe those
first couple of movies because so much
was on the line they had leveraged the
IP for all their characters so if their
movies didn't make money they would lose
the rights to all the Marvel characters
Kenneth Branagh also revealed there was
a big deleted scene in an alternate
opening the movie starts with Jane
Foster Erik Selvig and Darcy in the New
Mexico desert as Thor comes crashing to
earth via the Bifrost after being exiled
by Odin and stripped of his power or so
he thinks we would later learn about
this
during thor ragnarok later they was sort
of retcon Thor's power it doesn't come
from the hammer it comes from you that's
the MCU version of the Thor force that
they're talking about in the comics the
Thor force is what you call the
odinforce once he passes it to Thor and
Thor becomes the true king of Asgard
they do try to explain the odinforce a
little bit during this movie and during
thor ragnarok like they show Odin going
into the odinsleep to regenerate his
power but the odinforce is actually the
combined cosmic life energy of Odin and
his two brothers remember the scene at
the beginning of Thor Ragnarok where
Thor is making fun of Surtur didn't my
father kill you like a thousand years
ago or something the event that he's
referencing is actually the creation of
the odinforce in the comics Odin was
battling Serdar with his two brothers
and as they lay dying he absorbed their
life force in their combined cosmic
energies formed the Odin force within
him giving him a crazy powerup he used
that power to defeat Serdar which is
what Thor's referencing here there was
also a deleted scene from Thor Ragnarok
in the nfinity saga box set I did a
video for it so I'll link it in the
description but Odin passes the
odinforce to Thor I grant you my power
but originally kenneth branagh said that
the opening of the movie was meant to be
a look of the hubble space telescope
traveling through the nine realms
looking at all the different places the
nine realms because this was meant to be
Marvel's first big cosmic movie then we
get our big flashback to 965 tonsberg
norway this big battle between Odin and
the frost giants it's the same town at
the beginning of the Captain America
movie where Red Skull found the
tesseract in it's the same town where
Thor would later build new Asgard where
Odin died on the cliffs you look at the
sign here from avengers endgame it
literally says formerly known as ton's
burg they also used the flashback to
show you how odd and lost his eye to the
king of the frost giants in the battle
in the comics he actually willingly gave
up his eye to gain more cosmic wisdom
and power we talked about rune King Thor
being the most powerful version of Thor
in order to become rune King Thor in the
comics Thor had to give up both of his
eyes and therefore was able to wield a
much more powerful version of the
odinforce than Odin ever had the MCU
version of Thor would later lose his eye
in his quest to become a king while
fighting hella to keep her from taking
Asgard which is a big callback to this
moment you also noticed the timeline
because it's 9 6
d-5 ad Thor is already around 500 years
old he's about 1500 years old in present
day right after this battle is when he
would also steal Loki from the frost
giants they played a little fast and
loose with a timeline and their ages in
the movie because they're both portrayed
relatively soon after this as young boys
but you could just chalk that up to them
jumping forward in time through their
lives as they grow up but because this
is happening in 965 is happening after
he imprisoned hella after they conquered
the nine realms as hellah explains it
they were on a mission to conquer the
galaxy but stopped at nine realms we
travel back to Asgard and present-day
as Odin is getting ready to named Thor
the new king because he's getting ready
to go into the odinsleep in Asgard we'll
need a king while he's under they show
you that cool zoom in shot of Asgard as
they flip around it's meant to be a
contrast between Loki the ice mountain
underneath Asgard and Thor on top the
natural-born son of Odin it's also a
nice visual metaphor for their
relationship how they're both two sides
of one hold Thor can't be true king or
true hero without Loki's help
he's a core part of Thor's character
development we get a really good look
inside Odin's treasure vault which
contains a whole bunch of comic book
Easter eggs
there's the casket of ancient winters
which he stole from the frost giants a
fake Infinity Gauntlet which we've
talked about a whole bunch the tablet of
life and time which can actually extend
your life force the runes on it
translate to those who sit above in
shadow which is a reference to all the
Marvel Comics sky gods like Odin
there's the cosmic tuning fork which is
capable of summoning monsters the
eternal flame which we saw during Thor
Ragnarok and Surdas crown which both
grant him power and are all part of the
cycle of Ragnarok there's the warlocks
eye which can control other people's
minds which they would later reference
with the mine stone during the first
Avengers movie the destroyer and then
the entrance the Asgardian catacombs
that we saw during thor ragnarok where
most Asgardian Warriors are entombed
after they die
even though Odin enchanced the hammer
with a signature were the enchantment
later in the movie the Marvel designers
actually inscribed one on the top of the
hammer that you can see here it reads a
little bit differently it translates to
he who wields this hammer commands the
lightning in the storm it's a reference
to the cosmic storm that resides inside
the hammer the hammer itself has a scent
it's alive Odin forged it from the
essence of a living cosmic storm that
explains how the hammer decides who's
worthy and who is not now in the MCU we
know that each reforged the hammer which
they later reference forged inside a
dying star which Odin says we would
later visit that place when Thor went to
the dwarfs to forge Stormbreaker an
infinity war and while this whole
opening scene is all about Thor's
coronation in the frost giants attack
there was an alternate opening scene
here with an adult Loki in Thor just
showing off some of their personality
Thor smashes a goblet of mead yelling
for more just like he smashes the coffee
cup later in the movie Loki would also
use his magic to turn wine into snakes a
joke they would later reference during
Thor Ragnarok when Thor complained about
Loki turning things into snakes when
they were kids you noticed when Odin
calls Thor his firstborn Frigga gives
him a sideways glance because hella is
his firstborn
you see Odin's Ravens in the background
Hugin immune in thought and memory in
Marvel Comics they're actually not real
ravens they're just magical beings
capable of relaying information to Odin
from around the nine realms
during Thor the dark world they actually
brought the Ravens back when they became
Thor's Ravens because in the Ultra
ending to that movie he actually takes
the throne instead of Loki taking the
throne secretly pretending to be Odin
the frost giants attacked cutting the
coronation short looking manipulates
events to take the piss out of Thor
goading him to attack the frost giants
setting off the whole plot of the movie
we meet Heimdall ADRA's Elbe for the
first time who gives Loki a bunch of
sideways glances when talking about
never having let enemies slipped past
him before loki discovers his true past
as they attack the frost giants just as
odin comes to stop things from
escalating to all-out war the
eight-legged horse that he's riding is
actually right out of Norse mythology
once they arrive back the scene of Odin
ripping Thor apart like a piece of trash
is probably one of the best scenes that
they've ever had together too bad we
probably won't get to see this version
of Odin again maybe if they did some
crazy flashback version of Odin when he
was much much younger
Odin places the signature enchantment on
Mjolnir cast it down to earth to wait
for Thor if he can prove himself worthy
the town where they wind up in New
Mexico after Thor gets shocked Puente
antigo translates literally to antique
bridge a reference
to the Rainbow Bridge then they start to
use the Jane Foster storyline to try and
explain the magic of Thor and Asgard in
scientific terms magic is just highly
advanced science that we haven't learned
to describe yet she describes the
Bifrost as a wormhole generator Erik
Selvig later references the Hulk when
talking about this in a pioneer that he
knew in gamma radiation there was also a
deleted scene where references Hank Pym
then later in thor ragnarok they called
back to this when Hulk makes the same
reference talking about the devil's anus
going through the big one Devil's anus
he calls it another einstein-rosen
bridge but it's a naturally occurring
one whereas the Bifrost generates them
artificially and even though they only
use it a couple times during infinity
war and endgame Stormbreaker is also
capable of opening artificial Bifrost we
get all the funny moments with the
townspeople trying to lift Mjolnir the
first person here is a cameo by Thor
comic book writer J michael Straczynski
Thor writer Walt Simonson also has a
cameo in an Asgardian scene eating
dinner with the Warriors 3 and then
obviously we have our big Stan Lee cameo
as the guy who tries to use his truck to
tow Mjolnir away there was actually a
funny moment where you see his broken
truck driving up behind them when
they're in the diner scene they make a
reference to Thor's comic book identity
Donald Blake remember Marvel was kind of
done with the idea of secret identities
at least until we got to spider-man but
they've recently cast his secret
identity away - thank you very much
Mysterio there are a couple of Easter
eggs around town here you notice this
one reads journey into mystery which is
the comic book where Thor appeared for
the first time
Coulson shows up with shield to
confiscate all of Jane Foster's research
and Sitwell hail Hydra there was a
Marvel one-shot that they did that
showed you what happened on the way to
Thor's hammer it was literally called a
funny thing happened on the way to
Thor's hammer Kevin Feige said they
might even bring back the concept of
Marvel one-shots for Disney plus some
day back on Asgard Odin falls into the
odinsleep to regenerate his life force
leaving Loki free to claim the throne
then when we go back to Planet Earth and
they start doing research on Thor in the
library you notice there's an Easter Egg
for the tesseract here where he sees the
illustration of Thor and Odin crossing
the Bifrost to come to Planet Earth
holding this cube here this is depicting
the event where Odin brought the
tesseract back to Planet
to hide it in tønsberg when it would
then later show up at the beginning of
the Captain America movie Thor learns
about where his hammer is and we get our
first big Hawkeye MCU appearance when he
tries to steal it back
unsuccessfully Thor then explains the
nine realms in the history of Asgard to
Jane Foster the only place in the nine
realms so far we haven't been in the MCU
is actually Alfheim the place where the
light elves live
maybe they'll reference that somehow
during Thor 4 love and thunder
Loki puts his plot in motion to get rid
of Thor and the frost giants by sending
the destroyer to earth
Coulson makes a very timely Iron Man
joke because literally the destroyer is
a walking suit of armor that Gaia
doesn't tell me anything
Odin actually does grant all the
Avengers upgraded destroyer armor in the
comics at one point Thor then reclaims
his hammer smashes the destroyer in its
head he went for the head remember that
Loki winds up killing his biological
father revealing his true goals saving
odin then battles Thor who smashes the
Bifrost to keep Loki from totally
obliterating farth I'm Loki then let's
go as they try to save him falling into
the collapsing Bifrost portal taking him
to parts unknown which we would later
find out actually put him on Thanos
doorstep who would give him the mine
stone in exchange for his help in
collecting the space stone during the
first Avengers movie in the post-credits
scene we actually seen Nick Fury bring
Erik Selvig to project Pegasus to study
the tesseract Loki reappears secretly to
plot how he's going to take it from them
you look at all those city miles on his
face there and you can tell that a lot
of time has passed though he looks way
worse off than when he fell into that
Bifrost portal there was also a really
big Marvel phase 4 Easter egg in an
alternate ending of the movie this
deleted scene here shows Erik Selvig
referencing sword sword is the other
organization the Nick Fury forms in the
comics to protect Earth from threats
from outer space shield is mostly
concerned with threats from Planet Earth
sword is all about stuff from beyond
cosmic threats we would later see the
sword Space Station in the spider-man
far from home post credits scene but if
you think about the timeline if sword
existed this early in Marvel phase 1
Nick Fury knew about the scrolls since
the 90s that implies that he had been
building this space station long before
the events of Marvel phase
one even though we didn't see it till
after Avengers endgame it would also
explain why Nick Fury doesn't care that
they destroy the project Pegasus base at
the beginning of the Avengers movie
because he already knows that he has a
much more advanced orbital space station
I know a lot of you would say well if
the sword Space Station existed that
early in Marvel phase 1 how come we
didn't hear about it till now well
remember we know that the Kree in the
scrolls have cloaking technology like
Marvel spaceship was literally orbiting
around planet Earth
throughout the Captain Marvel movie
without anybody on earth knowing about
it so the sword Space Station has
probably just been cloaked from everyone
sensors this whole time
the next place we're going to see the sword
organization featured is during the
Wandavision series if you remember
Monica Rambeau she's a little girl
during the events of the Captain Marvel
movie well in present day after avengers
endgame when Wandavision takes place
she's an adult working for Nick Fury is
part of sword well let me know in the
comments if he spotted any big Marvel
phase 4 Easter eggs in the movie that I
didn't mention in the video my next big
MCU infiniti saga rewatched video will
be for the Captain America movie that
should post in the next week as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see that video when I posted
click here for all my infinity Saga
Marvel phase 4 Easter Egg rewatch videos
and click here for my brand new
spider-man 3 daredevil video thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!